Joe asks can anyone create good micro
content how can you make sure your team
consistently creates good content Joe
great question first for everybody's
watching and/or listening I want to talk
about the term micro content it's
something I started using three four
years ago it hasn't really caught on I
myself don't know how often I'm going to
use it going forward but the notion was
content made specifically for the
platform you know the videos and the
pictures the quotes the written words
that worked on Facebook Twitter Tumblr
Pinterest Instagram snapchat vine it was
the context of the book Jab Jab Jab
right hook you rod rode up there right
there show it I got it you got it okay
so you know how do you make good micro
content how do you consistently get your
team to do it
first of all content is subjective right
Steve likes Game of Thrones shows I
don't not that I don't like it I just
haven't even seen it yet some people
watch Game of Thrones and don't like it
very few I think cuz it's very popular
but you know it is still clearly
subjective that's number one number two
how do you get a team to be good at
anything when you're scaling you're kind
of POV on the world and marketing to a
400 person and downstairs a lot of
comments about downstairs will get their
organization it's about education but I
would actually say that for me scaling
and getting my team to get there has a
lot to do more with osmosis right like
putting it into the water stream versus
having a class that teaches it sure you
can write a book sure we have lunch and
learns and learn ups within the
organization but they're not attended
that well you need to talk about that by
the way what's happening more here is
people are doing and people are smart
you know it starts with hiring good
people smart people and then when you
realize you've hired somebody who's not
capable of learning through that process
well then you got to make some decisions
but to me making good content takes a
couple of core pillars number one you've
got to respect your audience meaning
you've got to respect the psychology of
what they're doing when they're on the
platform I know a 40 year old woman is
in a different mindset when she's on
Facebook versus when she's on Pinterest
and that is how I try to story tell to
her because I know I'm Pinterest
she has intent to shine
aspirational shop and on Facebook she's
keeping up with her world or consuming
information and so I strategize around
that the psychology and the platform
itself number two when I say respect I
put out content that I think she will
like versus what I'd like to accomplish
yes I'd like to give me a bottle wine
yes I'd like to
a little faster outside notes rose yes
I'd like to sell this but if I put it in
a way that is more interesting to her
five under $10 bottles of wine that you
know help you get through the day when
you have eight year-old kids and a new
target eight-year-old kid moms you're
gonna start getting into a game that
gives you a better chance you know 12
wines somebody who's 38 will like and
the new target people from that were
born in 1975 these are all strategies
that will work again a very heavy
Facebook or Instagram taking a glamour
shot of it in an angle and it's just
like cool and nice like it's all of that
kind of stuff respecting the audience
respecting the platform taking your
agenda and making it third oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe